Although much of the canon information about
the Mandalorian-Jedi War is still up in the air,
here's what we know so far. This is the
history of the Mandalorian-Jedi War explained.
As odd as it sounds, the war started because
the Mandalorians did not understand the Jedi
when they first encountered them. Even
at the end of The Mandalorian season 1,
the Armorer describes the Jedi
as "an order of sorcerers."
Due to this lack of understanding, the
Mandalorians created weapons and armor
to better combat these mysterious
new opponents. In 2017, Comicbook.com
interviewed Dave Filoni about
how the Star Wars: Rebels episode
"Trials of the Darksaber" referenced
the Mandalorian-Jedi War. He explained,
"The Mandalorian-Jedi War that
I have in my mind is very much
derived from the oldest style of thinking of
Mandalorians, which was that their weapons,
their arsenal, their technology had a massive
increase once they collided with the Jedi
and found these force-wielding people that
had abilities they didn't understand."
More and more animosity occurred between
the Mandalorians and Jedi once the latter
group started interfering with the former's
crusades. The 2016 reference book Star Wars:
Aliens of the Galaxy details how a
group of sword-wielding Mandalorians
known as the Mandalorian crusaders
carried out a series of conquests
across the galaxy. While in the Inner Rim, the
crusaders devastated a planet called Ubduria
out of contempt for the native Ubdurians,
who they viewed as dishonorable cowards.
The Mandalorian crusaders also fought the
Jedi at some point during these missions.
Murals of the Mandalorian crusaders fighting
the Jedi were created and can be seen in a few
episodes of Star Wars: The Clone Wars, as
well as one episode of Star Wars: Rebels.
Even though Mandalorians and Jedi were at one
point sworn enemies, a member of the former
group did create a lightsaber of his own. That
member was Tarre Vizsla, the first Mandalorian
ever inducted into the Jedi Order. Tarre created
a unique black-colored lightsaber called the
Darksaber during his time as a Jedi. After he
died, the Jedi kept the saber in the Jedi Temple,
but during the fall of the Old Republic, members
of House Vizsla raided that temple and reclaimed
the saber. They used it to unite their people and
defeat anyone who opposed them, including Jedi.
The Darksaber would become a symbol of power to
the Mandalorians and was used to unite them before
and after the Mandalorian-Jedi War.
The Mandalorian-Jedi War became so
heated that, near the end of their wars,
the Mandalorians turned Concordia, the moon
of their homeworld, into a mining base.
Although the Mandalorians put up
a good fight against the Jedi,
it was not enough to save their homeworld. The
Mandalorian-Jedi War ended with a final battle,
which caused a cataclysm that scorched much of
Mandalore into a white, uninhabitable wasteland.
The Jedi won the war, but not all
was lost for the Mandalorians,
as they created hermetically sealed
domed cities on Mandalore's surface.
Years after the Mandalorian-Jedi War ended,
many Mandalorians, including Satine Kryze,
did not want to continue the cycle of
violence that almost destroyed their planet.
They formed a peaceful movement
called the New Mandalorians.
Forty-two years before the Battle of Yavin, a
civil war broke out between the New Mandalorians
and the martial traditionalists who
both sought control for Mandalore.
The death toll during this war was a primary
reason why Satine became a pacifist for the rest
of her life. As duchess, Satine rebuilt Mandalore,
and it thrived under her leadership for 20 years.
Mandalore went on to become an active
participant in the senate of the Galactic
Republic while still remaining neutral
throughout the majority of the Clone Wars.
Of course, many Mandalorians still opposed
the New Mandalorians' pacifist ideals and
wanted to return Mandalore to its warrior ways.
These same Mandalorians would go on
to form the terrorist organization
Death Watch under the leadership of Governor
Pre Vizsla and Satine's sister, Bo-Katan Kryze.
Death Watch was initially aligned with Count
Dooku and the Separatists, but they parted ways
and eventually joined forces with a renegade Sith
lord named Maul to take over Mandalore together.
Maul and Vizsla devised a plan
to make the New Mandalorians look
weak in order to gain the people's trust.
"Death Watch is here to save
you from these intergalactic
gangsters that threaten our great city."
The plan was successfully carried out, and
Vizsla declared himself ruler of Mandalore,
but he betrayed Maul and imprisoned him.
It didn't take long for Maul to escape,
which allowed Maul to challenge
Vizsla to a duel, which he won.
After beheading Vizsla with the Darksaber,
Maul declared himself the new leader of
Death Watch and installed a puppet prime
minister while he ruled from the shadows.
After becoming ruler of Mandalore,
Maul retained the loyalty of most of
the members of Death Watch. But
some members, such as Bo-Katan,
could not accept the idea of an outsider ruling
Mandalore and led a resistance against him.
In the seventh season of The Clone Wars, Maul's
reign is cut short after former Jedi knight Ahsoka
Tano and Bo-Katan team up to launch a full-scale
assault in an attempt to liberate Mandalore from
the clutches of the Shadow Collective. Before
ordering the other Shadow Collective leaders to
go into hiding, Maul is captured but subsequently
escapes custody in the wake of Order 66.
The 2018 spinoff film Solo: A Star Wars Story,
set after the events of The Clone Wars season 7,
reveals that Maul established another
crime syndicate called the Crimson Dawn.
Even though Bo-Katan and her forces defeated Maul
and freed Mandalore from the Shadow Collective,
it didn't take long for the Empire to undo all
that progress. After Bo-Katan refuses to comply
with the imperial occupation of her homeworld,
Clan Saxon betrayed her and swore allegiance
to Emperor Palpatine. Fortunately, Bo-Katan joined
forces with Clan Wren, the Mandalorian Protectors,
and members of the Rebel Alliance
to fight back against Clan Saxon.
Following this victory, Bo-Katan was given the
Darksaber and took up the title of Mand'alor,
a title assumed by the sole
leader of the Mandalorian people.
Unfortunately, the Empire would strike back
against the remaining Mandalorians in the
form of the Great Purge. This event saw the
deaths of many Mandalorians across the galaxy
and the Empire stealing massive amounts of beskar,
a metal alloy that Mandalorians use
to create their signature armor.
In the season 1 finale of The Mandalorian,
the Tribe's Armorer tells Din Djarin that he
needs to reunite the Child with his people. That
mission sends Mando on a series of adventures,
including one that puts him in direct contact with
Bo-Katan and her fellow Mandalorian separatists.
Although they don't share Djarin's rigid
adherence to the Mandalorian creed Bo-Katan
ultimately helps him on his mission, in exchange
for his help in raiding an Imperial ship.
Mando is initially led to believe the separatists
are simply trying to steal weapons from the
shattered Empire, but it eventually becomes clear
that Bo-Katan is really after the Darksaber,
now wielded by Moff Gideon.
Living up to her end of the deal,
she tells Djarin where to find a Jedi,
telling him to seek out Ahsoka Tano.
Mando heads to the planet Corvus, a
deforested wasteland where Ahsoka Tano
has been waging a war against the brutal
reign of a figure known as the Magistrate.
Upon Mando's arrival, he's shepherded
to an audience with the Magistrate,
who offers him a staff made of pure beskar
in exchange for murdering Ahsoka. Instead,
he joins forces with Ahsoka following a brief
skirmish when they meet in the Corvus wastelands.
Mando offers to help Ahsoka defeat the
Magistrate in exchange for her accepting
and training the Child. As expected, the
Magistrate is no match for the duo, but
Ahsoka is unable to live up to her end of the
deal, telling Mando that she can't train the
Child. She's able to speak with him via
the Force, and learns that his real name
is Grogu— and that he was trained on Coruscant
before being taken during the fall of the Jedi.
But she also discovers a great deal of fear,
anger, and darkness in him, and having been
close to Anakin Skywalker, she's all too
aware of how those feelings can be exploited.
Although Ahsoka is unable or unwilling to train
Grogu, she offers Mando one other way to fulfill
his obligation — take him to the planet Tython,
where Grogu may be able to tap into the Force at
the site of some ancient temple ruins and
establish a connection with another Jedi.
In the middle of that process, however,
Grogu is kidnapped by Moff Gideon's forces.
Mando gathers a crew to overtake Gideon's
light cruiser and save the Child.
After reaching Grogu's cell, Mando battles Gideon,
ultimately Mando disarms Gideon with the Beskar
spear he received from Ahsoka back on Corvus.
After taking Grogu and a shackled Gideon to the
bridge, Mando offers the Darksaber to Bo-Katan,
but she refuses. Gideon clarifies
that the Darksaber cannot be given
and must be won in combat. Their stand-off is
interrupted when a Jedi, Luke Skywalker himself,
arrives to rescue them from a squad of Dark
Troopers and take Grogu away to be trained.
Will Mando and Grogu's connection last?
Or will the events of the Mandalorian-Jedi
war repeat themselves once again?
Check out one of our newest videos
right here! Plus, even more Looper
videos about your favorite Star
Wars histories are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.